you you mentioned uh how your son was in
school he started to wake up and stuff
this
this brings me to this next door we have
from the post millennial
ooh anti-critical race theory candidates
for school board when overwhelming
support from dallas parents
candidates who ran on an anti-critical
race three platform won two open school
board seats in dallas south lake
district on saturday
with a landslide almost 70 percent
majority i mean that's the bulk of the
story
i think again it's heavily focused on
race theory
and i think a lot of parents are
actually having a bigger reaction to
gender theory because the gender theory
is definitely coming down the road and a
lot of that originated in british
columbia in canada
um yeah and that you know you have the
gender unicorn and the gender
gingerbread man and it's been pushed
very heavily
ginger person the ginger yeah
gingerbread person not gingerbread man
of course
gender bread mix them or whatever you
know
but i think but yeah there's a couple
things that have happened here
and i'll you know try to be as
respectful and delicate as possible for
youtube and their
censors but uh there have been lawsuits
the the parents of young biological
females concerned about
their opportunities in athletics
resulted in lawsuits
yes we recently had caitlyn jenner who
is a trans woman come out and say that
it was unfair
but i think things like that so not to
derail too much but
it's not just race theory parents are
learning about all of these different
things and saying
hey you know wait a minute it's not fair
to discriminate against someone based on
their immutable characteristics that's
correct
and it's also not not right to tell
someone that their immutable
characteristics need to be changed in
order for them to be who they really are
since i wrote the story this summer
about
my son's education
a lot of parents reached out to me from
across the country to tell me about
their experiences and i had a mom
in california telling me about the
gender education that her child was
receiving and she had actually gone to
a school board meeting and had seen the
slides of
the way that the curriculum was going to
be implemented from kindergarten
all the way through 12th grade and it
starts off with a book about
a boy who wants to wear a dress and it
moves
right through you know gender transition
altogether and she moved her kid to
texas in order to get away from this
and i've recently been talking to a lot
of parents about how things are going
with regard to reopening schools
we had this promise from joe biden that
schools were going to be reopened at the
end of 100 days
and it's just not actually true
the schools are not open are you shocked
it's shocking this can't be right it
just can't be real ian do you believe
that joe biden would lie to us
[Laughter]
um and it turns out so my question
started to be what does open mean
what does that mean to you you know what
are your feelings about it
my personal truth in the word open means
closed right it turns out
that you would be correct uh a lot of
the schools are still closed schools
that were
closed in the fall are still closed
schools that were open in the fall are
still open
so the idea that anything that biden has
done
has actually resulted in reopening
schools is complete farce
i think we got to move to florida
everybody just just we keep talking
about that at post millennial
moving moving closer to florida we keep
being like hey let's just all move to
florida i don't want to derail just yet
but we will be talking about this new
this new bill that's on the verge of
getting passed which is going to change
the game in terms of social media and
what it means for you guys
but uh we'll we'll keep it on you know
the critical race here in the school
stuff for now we'll get to that later
but yeah i think a lot of parents
realized this and i think what we're
seeing is interesting with this one
story that you guys
a lot of people wrote about the story
but you know the one we just pulled up
this is a district that
uh narrowly went for biden by i think
like it was like five point swing so
it's like 47 for trump 52 for biden
the county went for trump so you know
depending on which metric you use you
can make an argument but i think when
you're looking at these suburbs which
they said
white affluent suburbs actually went for
biden more and trump actually lost white
voters and gained latinos and black
voters
the fact that you have white affluent
suburbanites
pushing back against this i think this
is where we see
traditional liberals falling asleep and
then those who are forced to wake up
really waking up and swinging a 70-point
you know lead for the anti-critical race
theory yeah what do you think can happen
in 2022
when these traditional libs are just not
paying attention and
the disaffected liberals who are are
like what is happening
there keep being more disaffected
liberals i used to work in theater
and i've heard from people who don't
want to be named and don't want to be
public
but they reach out to me and they're
like hey this stuff is crazy and i'm
like dude
i know i have been telling you for a
while that this stuff is crazy
and they don't want to believe it
because they were so
married to their ideology and you can't
be married to an ideology
there's there's just no sense in that
you constantly have to question it
if you don't know why you believe what
you believe then why do you believe it
it's really interesting talking to uh
someone who's particularly religious
like i was talking to michael knowles
man like like i mentioned we got over at
tmcst.com this longer bonus segment we
did with michael talking about religion
for like an hour and
ian we're talking about space and
everything and it's really fascinating
and then after even even after the show
you know we're hanging out just chilling
and having this
conversation michael knows a lot
now maybe it's not fair to compare like
your average liberal to someone as
well read as michael knowles but every
conversation i have with someone who is
religious and like legitimately they can
tell me some things about it why they
believe it i understand there are a lot
of people who are probably just like i
don't know and
and you know i wouldn't say that they're
you know i don't know
it it exists but if i take the average
like i'm trying to avoid calling people
out but
we've spoken with people even on this
show who could not tell us what was
going on with critical race theory
why they would support it or oppose it
granted destiny actually really did so
there's a
you're familiar with destiny right yeah
he actually knew a ton about it
and actually articulated why he was four
and i was impressed with that because i
talked to a lot of people who have you
know prominent channels and they're like
well i mean
it's just like you oppose racism right
and i'm like is that what you really
think like did you actually read any of
this stuff right
like we're looking at you look at some
of christopher ruffo's research and it's
like
a laboratory sending white people on a
retreat to condemn white people like
that's that's against this violation of
the
1964 civil rights act yes so i started i
talked to so many conservatives about
religion
and they'll talk about what the saint
said or what they learned in you know
this chapter or this first like they
actually did some research or reading
and then i talked to my my liberal
friends who are following this stuff my
progressive friends
and they don't know anything about the
roots they don't know anything about
where it comes from or what it means
and i think that's really i think it's
interesting i think it says a lot
i think it says a lot about our
educational system i think it says a lot
about
um you know where all of that stuff
landed so
the people who are liberals now were
educated
in a college system in a high school
system you know
that um basically gave all of this stuff
as
gospel this is what you were supposed to
believe and what has happened
is that critical race and gender theory
and
i would even say you know the concept of
climate alarmism
these are all concepts that are opinions
right
and they are dictated to children
and children form have the opinions by
wrote
they have the opinions before they have
the information
so they take their opinion and then once
they're taught the actual information
they already have been told how to think
about it so that's not
you know that's not going to be
effective in terms of creating people
who can think for themselves
you need to provide the information and
then you need to say
these people think this about it these
people think this about it
what do you think about it synthesize
that information synthesize the opinions
think critically about it yourself and
come up with what you think
and if we're not doing that we're just
creating a generation of
stupid manageable children you know i
was uh
on the way back the other day i was
thinking about i can't remember exactly
what happened what made me think about
this but
people just don't care about their
community anymore and so you mentioned
these are opinions being dictated to
children more than you probably realize
i think most of these things that we
learn are actually opinions but they're
expert opinions
right there's a difference between like
some regular guy in the street being
like the sky is you know
made like the clouds are made of
marshmallow and you're like okay dude
that's not an opinion that's
like crazy and so there are things we
believe to be fact
there are things that are fact when it
comes to science we have the challenge
of
trusting people and so when it comes to
a scientist telling you what a cloud is
she's like have you ever really gone up
there and actually
like done the research to prove it
that's water vapor you haven't
but most people reasonably conclude some
things are true like if i throw a rock
at a window the window will likely break
there's a fact
when it comes to a lot of things that we
teach children they're actually just
expert opinions based on available data
that's why science changes so often
right so i guess
it's it's fair to say to a certain
degree we we suspect these things
are facts science eventually gets that
point but what's happened is
this this understanding of history
and science is being exploited by what i
refer to as the cult
i think there's any case occult is cause
it's like a religion with no nucleus no
moral foundation right
so what they see is hey wait a minute
when you tell these kids something based
off the available data it's an expert
analysis that you believe to be true now
obviously some things are tested
and there are control groups there are
some things we don't have control groups
for which make it very difficult
notably climate change right there's no
control plan it's very difficult however
i
i do fall into the category of someone
who believes climate change is an issue
i think
humans mass consume will lead to serious
problems
to me that just feels like based on
everything i've seen it kind of
mathematically adds up to this point
however
that's just me trusting it's also me
just giving me giving an analogy
my personal analysis of someone who
reads the news for a lot of these
scientists they're experts who have
availability of lots of data and can
draw a conclusion but this is why
science is often wrong
exploiting that system is very easy and
that's what the critical race theorists
the critical theorists are doing
the difference is there's actually
climate data now
granted some people don't agree with it
don't believe it i have anything that's
incorrect
but when it comes to critical race
theory what you have there is
we made up a thing that we think is true
we think one race is
you know mean to the other race there's
no hard data there's no numbers
we can argue numbers we can argue
science around
you know ice shelves or something like
that well but with critical race theory
they're taking data from
you know 50 70 years ago and they're
using it as though that data is still
relevant for society today
and that's a big problem it's like it it
completely
eradicates the civil rights movement uh
maxine waters saying that the country is
getting more racist every day she's a
she's a sitting congresswoman from the
state of california and she has been for
a very long time
she's a lot of power she's a pretty bad
job of ending racism i guess yeah she
you know
and you have biden talking about
systemic racism
well he's been in federal government
since the 70s
where has he been what has he been doing
about it oh he was making that system
he was you know working on it i guess
real hard the other direction
um yeah you know i just don't think that
uh
and anyway all of this stuff is being
taught
um because the people who are teaching
it have an agenda
and not the people who are teaching it
but it's coming down even be
from not from the teachers themselves
like in new york city you had
uh and he's not there anymore but you
had richard karanza who was the school's
chancellor
and he was basically dictating this kind
of education he was saying that it had
to be that way
under the obama administration we had
common core curriculum come in
which basically what it does is it
teaches the same subject
uh like the same sort of content in
every subject
so in math you're learning about racism
in english class you're learning about
research
well common core what it does is it
links all of the things that you're
learning
around sort of one kind of subject
so you're learning about one thing in
all of your disciplines
and that you know that's something that
happened under that because it was
supposedly
easier to study study things that way
but when you don't allow teachers to
design their own curriculum
i think that's a problem we have really
intelligent teachers
they should have a little more say over
how they they educate the kids in their
charge
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you